(placid music)
- [Jaden] On the surface,
it looks like Apple is
having a pretty good year.
After all, it did become the world's
most valuable publicly traded company.
But behind the scenes,
it's longstanding disputes
with app developers are
bubbling over into public view.
- Apple is facing backlash
over the way it runs the App Store
at a time when the App Store
is a key part of its business.
- [Jaden] Queue the
"Fortnite" gaming controversy
(placid music)
Over the summer, Epic
Games publicly rebelled
against the App Store's 30% fees
and urged players to join
its fight against Apple.
- Ladies and gentlemen, Apple
just banned "Fortnite", what?
- It's going down,
Apple versus "Fortnite".
- They're probably the one
company out there right now
that is so beloved by the public
that they'll be able to at
least put up the best fight.
- [Jaden] It's not just Epic Games.
Spotify, Airbnb, Tinder,
Facebook and Netflix
have all had disputes with
Apple over App Store rules,
all while lawmakers are scrutinizing Apple
and other tech companies for
potential antitrust violations.
- What's to stop Apple
from increasing it's commission to 50%?
- We, sir, we have never
increased commissions
in the store since the first
day it operated in 2008.
- [Jaden] So, what are
app makers asking for
and is Apple going to listen?
First, it's important to understand
how crucial the App Store has
become to Apple's business.
In recent years, Apple's
been shifting its focus
from selling more devices like iPhones
to selling more software and services.
Think Apple Music, Apple Care,
and of course the App Store.
- Apple One gives you and your family
all the services you
love in one simple plan,
- [Jaden] In 2020, its services business,
which includes the App Store,
helped the company set a new sales record
in the June quarter.
Apple doesn't break out
its App Store revenue,
but analysts estimate it
brought in roughly $17.5 billion
for fiscal year 2020.
(placid music)
Some apps and services
are particularly important
for the App Store
ecosystem, like "Fortnite".
The game has more than a
hundred million registered users
on Apple devices.
That's produced more
than a billion dollars
in global App Store spending
since its launch in 2018.
But in August, "Fortnite" was kicked
off the App Store altogether.
That's because the games
creator, Epic Games,
set up a system to get
money directly from players
without paying Apple its cut.
Apple takes a 30%
commission on sales of apps
and in app purchases.
So, if an app costs 4.99 upfront,
Apple collects a dollar 50,
while the app creator gets the rest,
same goes for if you use an
app to buy digital goods,
like virtual weapons or
sign up for a subscription
to a monthly service,
but the fee doesn't apply to
physical goods and services,
like clothing purchases or home rentals.
- What Epic Games did was it
tried to skirt that commission
by adding its own payment
system to the "Fortnite" app
on iPhones and iPads.
That goes against Apple's rules.
Apple pulled "Fortnite" from
the App Store, Epic sued Apple,
and then Apple filed a counter suit.
- [Jaden] Google pulled
"Fortnite" from Google Play
in August for the same reason.
And since the two
companies banned the app,
their monthly revenue from
the game has taken a big hit.
- From a developer perspective,
it definitely feels
like we're forced to pay
30% right off the top.
- [Jaden] Austin Benson
developed an app for Apple
and Android called Hang that
helped organize meetups.
And he's currently a CTO
at a small tech startup.
- It literally feels like a tax
and those dollars don't really go
towards a government to
pay roads and bridges.
They go to pay two of the biggest
and arguably most powerful
corporations in the world.
- [Jaden] In late September,
Spotify, the owner of Tinder
and Epic Games teamed up
to pressure Apple and
other App Store operators
to change their rules.
Apple and Google have defended
their business practices,
saying the commission fees are necessary
because of the services
the stores provide,
including security and
safeguarding user privacy.
(placid music)
In some cases,
the battle over App Store fees
has also spilled over into accusations
of Apple allegedly stifling competition.
Enter Spotify's fight with Apple.
In 2019, Spotify filed a
formal complaint to the EU,
accusing Apple of making
it difficult for rivals
of Apple Music to promote
their subscription services
without using Apple's payment system.
Apple takes a 30% cut on subscriptions
for the first year and
15% the second year.
- [Announcer] If you were to
upgrade to premium in our app
through the App Store,
we'd have to give Apple a whopping 30%
of your subscription fee.
- [Jaden] Spotify didn't
want to pay that fee
on its premium subscription revenue.
So, it removed the option to
sign up from within the app.
Users can still register
on Spotify's website,
but Apple's rules don't
allow Spotify to direct users
from the app to its site.
Netflix has taken a similar approach,
telling users you can't sign
up for Netflix in the app,
and Tinder charges members
more to sign up in the app
compared to its website.
Apple said that developers are free
to promote other pricing
outside of the App Store,
including on television and billboards.
- Certainly, when you see
the big headway companies
like Netflix and Spotify make that move,
you can imagine that other companies
are considering the same thing,
but if you'll look at a
Netflix and a Spotify,
they're in a better position
in the market themselves.
So, they could potentially
do say a TV commercial
that says sign up here.
Smaller companies may
not have that ability.
- [Jaden] Apple has said it doesn't
give its own products an advantage
and that its 30% fee is in line
with the rest of the industry.
But if you're an app developer,
your business largely depends
on just two companies,
Apple and Google.
(placid music)
Roughly 95% of all mobile
app spending in the U.S.
happens on the App Store in Google Play.
- We have Congress, the
Department of Justice,
the European Union, the FTC,
they're all investigating Apple
and other technology giants
too on antitrust grounds.
Google and Amazon and Facebook,
they're under the spotlight as well.
The tension though with Apple
by these government entities,
though, has so far centered
largely around the App Store
and the App Store has become,
essentially, Apple's bread and butter.
- [Jaden] In late September,
Apple said it would exempt some apps
from paying commissions on virtual events
hosted during the pandemic.
But many app makers say they want Apple
to review its commission
policies altogether.
And Apple's legal battles
aren't going away anytime soon.
Depending on how things play out,
the "Fortnite" case could
have a lasting impact
on how much revenue
developers are able to keep
and how apps accept payments altogether.
- The biggest thing that I'm
watching on the sidelines
is is Apple going to continue to take 30%?
Because that is just a
large number off the top.
Which means I have that
much less to hire sales
and marketing teams,
hire other developers,
and get my product out to other people.
And it makes it that much harder
as a small business to survive.
- There are all sorts of possibilities
as to what could happen or
things could stay the status quo.
But given the importance of the App Store
to Apple's bottom line,
should the outcome be such changes,
that could have a serious
effect on Apple's finances.